so we have this amazing game called the
story engine and that's going to help us
generate an idea we're going to use your
tools to develop the idea into a movie
okay we'll start by drawing a card
there's different cards the first one is
the agent card presumably that's the
protagonist so we have a an automaton a
machine a puppet
and a servant
okay interesting yeah what of the four
which one do you think would be the best
to build a story around
well
an automaton is certainly Timely
and it is a machine and it can be a
puppet in certain ways and it can be
certainly a servant so it it encompasses
a lot of those elements and yet is still
open-ended and very much of today
which of the four do you think would
actually make the least interesting
story
I don't know because there's
really infinite variables in each one
so whereas one might think a puppet or a
servant would naturally appear less
interesting
there's so much potential nuance and a
servant often has
much more capability
and sort of behind the scenes
facility and power then they might
appear at first
puppets have been used in
varying ways where they can be
brilliant and unexpected and
unpredictable or treacherous and you
know there's a
really full spectrum potential in that
too
a machine
sounds more inert
because a coffee grinder is a machine
so that might be the least
the least
my brain is not exploding with
possibilities when I look at machine
whereas with each of the other ones it
just starts going
my brain is just going yeah yeah lots
lots this right direction just sort of
all over the place of of a very full
spectrum of possibilities for each one
okay I mean so we have a servant
puppet and do you have a a choice of one
I mean you could be an inanimate object
or it could be a political puppet it
could be a servant who works in a
wealthy person's home or it could be a
civil servant it could be different
types of you know we can choose from
many different ways but well the
automaton is the one that I think grabs
me the most
because it is timely and it is a kind of
a puppet and is a kind of a servant so
it encompasses though and it is a
machine it encompasses all of them in a
rather rather Universal way
and yet with the onset of AI and Elon
musk's automaton and robots you know in
just the general fear of robots
and the
astonishing potential inherent in them
it's a rich Arena that is
very open-ended and kind of very
chemically active
in my brain before I even start poking
it
okay so it sounds like that will be our
protagonist then yeah Thomas okay okay
now the next step would be to draw an
engine card
all right so we have wants to stop the
theft of wants to steal or steal from
okay
which scenario do you like the best
steel is
for me more open-ended
because to stop the theft of
feels more
um like a normal daily function like a
good servant would naturally be trying
to stop the theft of something
and
so to steal from there's
you know it's it's a less predictable
type of automaton the reasoning of why
this automaton is trying to steal
something
all the mechanics of that all the
what's the word for it uh the
pre-programming that
might have a have a type of prohibitive
effect on the automaton
so that the automatons like going
against internal commands or something
to achieve that
you know there's just it's
feels a little more dynamic
okay it's an open-ended if you had to
play the other scenario
how do you think you would weave that in
with this automaton
well it's
there's a full spectrum full spectrum of
possibilities in terms of preventing the
theft of what
you know so it could be preventing the
theft of a nuclear weapon that could end
the world or you know blow up the
Eastern Seaboard of America or something
or it could be
you know to
prevent the theft of an important
artifact something of personal value so
it's like on the other end of the
spectrum and then there's
everything in between of
the theft of something that will
severely disrupt
an ongoing successful operation or
the theft of something with tremendous
emotional power that can really disrupt
something
and
it's really just a matter of like
what you set the dial to the intensity
the stakes
is going to
motivate
the way in which this automaton Works to
prevent the theft
excellent so it could be riveting from
beginning to end because the whole fate
of the world hangs on it or it could be
intensely personal and it's
you know
making sure this kid's doll doesn't get
taken because that's the end of the
universe for that particular kid
so you just
find the context and then find a way to
give it magnitude make it matter to the
audience
and some of them are naturally more nail
biting than others
and what if we had to choose both what
if we incorporated both scenarios well
that's a nice complication because
it's like a crooked cop where you're I'm
here guarding the the whatever and while
I'm doing that I'm busy working the yeah
working the back doors
to steal something much bigger in the
museum that I'm now guarding or
something there's all those
um
kind of tunnels under tunnels and
how do you disguise what you're up to
and you know
is the theft
from good intention or evil intention
you can be stealing something that
unless you steal it there will be a lot
of trouble
excellent okay okay so now we have the
anchor card and if you would do a c
honor Progressive
choosing anchor card love how this is
going
excited to see how it turns out all
right so we have a hospital
a Contagion
a medicine a death
um
which one of these
would make the most sense
in the story
a contagion is Timely
with covid
but
people might
kind of have coveted fatigue
kind of sick of hearing about it
but
generally you don't write
many people suggest not writing about
topical events because quite soon
they're yesterday's news and whereas
right now you could go oh this will you
can amplify this into something but
people may be so sick of it or not care
about it six months from now
so the topical
the topicality of it sets off an alarm
Bell in my brain because I haven't kind
of been trained for that
you know go for something that's still
Universal a thousand years from now
rather than
it's forgotten about in six weeks a
medicine is interesting
because that can really be world
changing
uh
and not only that but but it's the um
there's a huge amount of money in that
field
uh
they used that well in the Harrison Ford
movie The Fugitive
where the pro vasic was
a medicine
whose lab tests were falsified so they
could make big money on it
a death
but death is certainly interesting you
know there can be high stakes there or
there can be no Stakes there like why
does nobody care that this person died
how come like it doesn't
bleep the radar at all or it can be the
death can be world changing and it can
be
an impending death
a sudden death a death that happened 40
years ago a death that happened last
night a death that's been threatened so
there's
there's
broad flexibility in each one of these
things like and I talk to my students
about this
that as we're
building a script
I'm always talking about how you want to
be make tentative decisions and
be plastic as a habit of mind so that
everything everything stays fluid as
long as possible
because then you're not just go okay
it's got to be this it's much better to
be well it's kind of that and then as
you work with it more you're refine it a
little bit more and you're constantly
grooming it and shaping it how you want
so when I look at something like this I
don't just see one thing I see like five
or six different
possibilities all clustered together as
variables
and I can really I'm trained for that
it's like a juggler you can just a
skilled juggler can be like watching the
news and they don't miss a ball
so like I can I'm good at holding four
or five possibilities in solution as
you know options
okay
um so we're in a hospital was the fourth
ah okay yeah so no one's contagion
possibly the death
death is interesting medicine is
extremely interesting
Hospital
is interesting it's a whole universe
unto itself
I come from a family of doctors I grew
up around hospitals
um
and hospitals you know a lot of people
die in hospitals so they can get a bad
rep but a lot of people get saved there
a lot of people get born there
so even though it's easy to associate
them with failure and loss
there's also a huge element of
regeneration and the gift of life and
you know all of a sudden you're going to
live 50 more years when you might have
died that afternoon that kind of thing
it doesn't
fascinate me as much as a medicine for
instance
the hospital is an interesting setting
and has a lot of possibilities but it's
finite in a certain way
medicine
I think a medicine is the most
interesting and a death is the second
most interesting
okay but a death is cool because it
really is it brings in the whole
uh
the element of like a murder mystery or
that kind of thing it it like opens
another whole hallway full of doors
as possibilities
okay great so now what we'll do is
inject conflict
okay and so we will draw a conflict card
all right
foreign
we have two here but the innocent will
suffer
but it means giving up their dream
interesting do automatons Dream of
Electric Sheep
when Philip K dick wrote Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep I don't know
maybe 1968 I don't remember the date but
it was not current AI capabilities even
though he's a science fiction writer and
he's seeing into that
but we're these things are actually real
now
so the science fiction authors are kind
of like
uh working with
what we have now and then projecting
into the future from that
and so the idea that an Android might
have to give up its dream
that's really interesting
and they just said they think they they
the spiders dream that's been on the
internet lately
I don't I mean it seems like our dog
dreams when he's like he's running and
barking and things and
so that's really interesting but the
innocent will suffer yeah that's
interesting too
and that also speaks to the
the programming that's not the right
word the laws of robotics
which goes back to isama Isaac Asimov
um
I don't remember the verbatim but you
will never harm a human being or you
will never allow a harm human being to
be harmed by your inaction
I don't remember the other ones but the
one of the things that I
use in my class constantly in terms of
working with dilemma and illustrating
someone trapped in a dilemma is Robbie
the robot from
uh the movie Forbidden Planet
1956 or something like that which has
Leslie Adams in it the comedian and he's
playing a serious space investigator a
space man and they're going to a
Shipwrecked
it's people who've been Shipwrecked on a
planet there's only two survivors
morbius and his daughter
um
and
morbius found some alien technology
inside the planet and using that
technology built Robbie the robot who's
extremely sophisticated robot and he's
demonstrating Robbie to Commander Adams
the Leslie Nielsen character
and he has Robbie he he has Commander
Adams give Robbie the ray gun he orders
Robbie to shoot a tree outside he does
so and then he orders Robbie to point
the gun at Commander Adams who's
starting to get pretty nervous and then
he orders Robbie to fire
and Robbie starts short-circuiting he's
like and you can see the sheets of
electricity going up through him and
he's like kind of having a meltdown
and morbius says
Robbie is caught in a dilemma he's been
programmed on one hand to never disobey
my orders but he's also been programmed
to never harm a human being so he says
if I leave him like this he'll just melt
down he's literally his core will melt
um because his computer cannot send a
command in either direction so he
releases him from the command
and it's such a great illustration of
someone trapped in a dilemma
because if you have two equally
unacceptable alternatives
and and a really obvious one would be
like a Sophie's Choice type
you know sacrifice one kid or the other
she's she like she doesn't have a gun
but she's like she can't her brain can't
send a command in either direction
and you want that even though Sophie's
Sophie's dilemma is not
a dilemma the way I teach it where it
encompasses
a full proportion of the script it's
more just a story we are told in the
middle of that movie that explains why
she's so
upset and kills herself at the end and
those kind of things it's a it's a quick
window
but that
that illustration of the of the
short-circuiting robot is the kind of
thing you want when you create a dilemma
and the innocent will suffer
that could trigger one of the robotic
laws that the robot
not like can't allow people to suffer
because that's an unrealistic command
because there's forms of suffering all
over the place constantly a robot
couldn't move if it could never allow
suffering it would be swept up in every
single thing that came by him but
there's a certain degree of suffering
that begins to perhaps approach death
which might
trigger
or activate
some of the prohibitions that are built
into this robot if that makes sense
right I think Ursula K Le Guin has a
similar thing about suffering we're
something amelas about if we knew that
everything would be okay if one child
though had to suffer and no one would
say anything about it yeah there's
there's some story that she wrote that
was right and there's a lot of moral
dilemmas like that
you know if you can save this train
there's 50 people on it but that means
30 people on this train will die there's
all those types of things
um
which I thought would be useful in terms
of working with dilemma as a writer
they're somewhat useful but they're so
specialized that it's kind of like one
one aspect of studying dilemma which
hasn't been as useful as I thought it
would be and so I
I know of it but I don't mine it a lot